You're listening to radiolab
from public radio, w.N y.
S. T. E. N. N. P. R. Hello.
Hello. Hello. Hello.
Today I want to start the show by telling
you about a guy with a very, very,
very important man. Probably
one of the most important guys.
And guide them. Yes. Okay.
Tell me the correct
pronunciation on a Leo Leo.
Leo Can Hook in the way that you should
say is something like 11 Herc and here,
thankfully,
to help with our pronunciation and to
fill in the details is professor Matthew
Cobb. I'm the program director for
Zoology at the University of Manchester,
leaving hope,
and I've written a book about this called
generation the 17th century scientists
who unraveled the secrets of sex, life
and growth. Okay, so Lavan Hook. Yeah,
that's fine. Okay, so what did he
do? He was a draper. Draper. Yeah,
so he just so cloth. Oh, hey. He had
no scientific training whatsoever.
He was interested in microscopes.
Why would a draper be
interested in microscopes? Is
this hobby, is what he did.
He made these microscopes and he was
actually really good. That's right.
Although you have to keep in mind that
microscopes at that point in time talking
1670s here, it's not exactly
how we think of them now.
Back then they were just tiny
balls of glass and that's it.
And Science itself was
just a wee little baby.
You gotta just really
put yourself back. Okay.
There was Lavan Hook doing really well
with these microscopes and pretty soon
scientists all over the place. We're
asking you to look at stuff, for example,
um, what's in blood or what's
in sweat or what's in semen.
Dentata this is where it
does get rather sorted. Okay.
So Chad, before you do, I would just,
this is a point where we should tell
our audience that some of the references
from here on in will be a bit
graphic. If you don't want to it,
we don't want to hear that stuff. Now
go out to the garden and you know,
check out the rats. All right.
Okay. Now getting back to the story,
it's 1667 just imagine and losing hope
has just received a letter from the Royal
Society of London.
This big group of scientists asking
him to take a look at a drop of humans.
Seems to see what's in that, and not
to be graphic, but one Autumn Day,
Autumn 1677 he is in his bedroom having
conjugal relations with his wife,
Cornelia.
He's got his microscope ready plus a
little vial and then as he put it within
six beats of the posts,
after he ejaculated,
he'd got the seaman and he put it
into this very thin cappelary tube,
rushed over to the window. His
wife's laying there thinking, well,
what the hell are you doing?
Not Again, come on. Well,
you I know for the microscopes
already, and then he looks into the,
into the semen and he can
clearly see that there's a thing,
there's something in there,
some kind of small structure,
[inaudible] focuses.
He can see all these wriggling things.
He's just full,
absolutely full of these tiny eel like
things that he says are vast number of
living animal, cute animal
bodies were rounded,
furnished with a long thing tail.
They moved with a snake like
motion of the tail as eels
do when swimming in water.
[inaudible]
so what was he thinking at this
point? Do we know? I don't know.
I putting myself in his place. I
think, wow. Because here's the thing.
At this point in time, people didn't
really understand where babies came from.
They knew it had something to do
with sex. But the notion of heredity,
we are still very fuzzy.
And how a baby developed
was a total mystery. What's life?
How would you know if
something's alive in those days?
One of the main things that
they associated with life
was movement, isn't it?
It stuff moved. It was alive.
So if movement is the key,
you can imagine what labor and hooked
must've been thinking staring at these
wriggling little beasts
in the vial because they
[inaudible] that's right here.
Oh boy, did they move? These things are
trying to get somewhere that thrashing,
that desperate maybe in this
vile is the secret to life.
No
to the soul. This is what people
thought it didn't take long before.
Pretty fantastic idea began to circulate,
which is that not only is the sperm,
the vehicle of the soul,
but if you could somehow zoom all
the way down into its little head,
you would find in there a
little man, hello, hello.
This little chap or hunched
up, little tiny guy,
Tony human thinking was that one
day when the microscopes got better,
you'd actually be able to see that tiny
little human with your own eyes because
it had to be there because if the
sperm was the sole source of life,
then there must be something in there
that look pretty much like a human being.
One problem though. What if you were
one of these folks who believed yes,
but the sperm was the sole? Well
then you had to ask yourself,
what is the say about God?
Because it would mean he was creating
all these souls and then he was just
wasting them lave and
Herc did a calculation.
He worked out that there were more seaman,
more spermatozoa in an ejaculate of a cod.
He got a card and he opened it up and
saw how many sperm they must be in.
It's a jacket. And he said
there he was pretty much right.
There are more sperm in this ejaculate
than there are human beings alive on the
planet. And that's just in one cod.
What? That's true. Yeah. Holy Moly.
So you imagine all the men producing
all this stuff all the time.
Best an awful lot of souls if they're
all potentially human beings just dying.
Well, oh, but one. How many
spare Mary in a human ejaculate,
but 180 million. Oh, see that's nothing
these days. Yeah, it's like Brooklyn.
You just there. All right. This is radio
lab from Genova, I, Robert Krulwich,
and our program today is about the
way 180 million is still alive.
It's not a lot.
It's something that you only have a couple
of eggs who has a cup of [inaudible],
has a couple of eggs.
She's got a finite number.
Where's the guy is making millions every
day. Oh wait. Oh, that's right. Anyhow,
our program today is about
sperm. Yup. Stick around
[inaudible].
Okay. In all seriousness,
before we get started for real,
just wanted to tell you that that this
program does actually contain strong
sexual material and nothing too graphic,
but this is your warning
stick around. It'll be okay.
For those of us whose we may, let's
get back to our basic question,
the why so many questions. Yes.
Why is there such a startling asymmetry
between number of sexual sales produced
by a male and the very relatively few
eggs in the female? Well, of course,
this is the question I put the question
to. One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10. There's a lot
of English people in this show today.
[inaudible] work at the University of
Sheffield in the Department of animal and
plant sciences and he is an
expert on sperm in birth.
[inaudible]
you choose this line of work.
Ever since I was a teenager,
I was obsessed by birds.
I was also obsessed by sex and I managed
to combine the two into an academic
career. Isn't that lucky?
In any case. He says this
question of waistline, earth,
did God make so many sperm? It
just didn't seem very sensitive.
Well, this question not
only troubled the church at
Flamingo Science Flomex does I think the
right words I mixed scientists for for
a very long time.
It really wasn't until about the 1970s
that finally the large numbers of sperm
that males transfer to females
finally began to make sense.
What happened in the 1970s well before
the 1970s bird scientist assumed that if
a female chose a spouse for the season,
she would stick to the spouse for
the season, she would be faithful.
But in the 70s when they
looked a little more closely,
they found there was
one more to this story.
Springtime in Somerset,
the female bushy tailed with the well
is always present in words like this.
Always searching for that
springtime joy of love, a love song.
He's skinny, beautiful as is he
any condoms
and then is the act of love consummated
rather quickly and now he's off to get
his new sweetheart. Juicy. Well,
she's [inaudible] for the time and she,
and actually she's hoping
off to to another Bronx. Um,
it seems to be another main
[inaudible] oil to this first part.
[inaudible]
hype prior to the 1970s, if
people saw females behaving promiscuously,
they assumed that there was
something wrong with them.
What is wrong with this
bird? You have another bed,
a lunch,
if you've got another hormone imbalances
or some kind of misunderstanding.
But then they discovered DNA
fingerprints, the DNA test,
which provided a completely
unequivocal test of paternity.
They'd go to a nest, say and look
at the five eggs in the nest,
test the DNA and discover that some
of those eggs came from different dads
indicating the female had
mated with more than one male.
What are these four man as a father?
But you don't know which one [inaudible]
DNA fingerprinting gave us the evidence
that in fact the majority of animals,
the females are promiscuous. Really?
I mean this is like chimp babies,
chickadee babies, chipmunk
babies. Almost ubiquitous.
Let's find out the truth.
You are not the father
at the moment. I'm only talking
about a non humans, right?
But what does this female promiscuity
thing have to do with the why so much
sperm connects that we think because once
people understood that that was going
on, well then the level of competition
between males gets actually much more
complicated. When you mean, well,
if I am chasing the lady now,
not only do I have to
worry about a competitor,
but I have to worry about all the people
I've never met who have been having sex
with my girl. There's a whole level of,
oh you mean like the sperm is a complete
room is competing with just the makers
of the sperm, but the sperm
itself is sperm itself.
So there's outdoor competition, but now
there's indoor competition. Exactly.
If you get my drift,
one very effective way of competing is
simply to produce more sperm than the
next guy.
[inaudible]
okay, look, we need to
step back a little bit.
If females are promiscuous,
natural selection is going to favor
the male that wins and fertilizers that
particular females eggs.
As a consequence of that,
males have evolved the most staggering
array of adaptations to minimize their
own chances of being cuckolded.
What does cuckolded mean?
Cuckolding means your wife is cheating
on you and you don't know it. Oh,
so what he's saying is that animals
will go to elaborate lengths to beat,
not cheated on. In fact,
let me give you three spec
illustrations as never before
heard on Albert program.
When wouldn't it again,
which includes most things with sperm
competition as this played by [inaudible],
the rogue beetle
[inaudible]. These beetles are
amazing. When the male B dog,
the male Rovio has sex
with a female. So is Tim.
They transfer this berm and basically a
package of sperm called spur motto for
once it's inside the female,
it starts to [inaudible]. Well,
expand like a balloon. Yes.
In swelling and expanding.
It pushes out or away any rivals.
Hey, hey, but the sperm is stuck in a
balloon. It's gotta get out. Oh yes.
Well, but the lady Rove Beetle has
the Lukens structure of structure,
like a two that will [inaudible] the
spray for releasing the male's sperm.
No kidding. Yeah, it was
kind of like science fiction.
But if you think the role of beetle
has got something going on, let's meet.
Um,
males have the most elaborate and
bizarre penis is covered with backwards
pointing spines, hundreds of backward
pointing spines, kind of like, uh,
you know, bristles on a pipe cleaner
and a very clever guy called Jeff wog.
He did a very clever experiment.
He allowed male drag and tries to mate
with females and separated them at
different stages during their
rather protracted copulation.
And what he found was halfway
through the copulation,
the male before he actually
does the act is actually moving
his penis from the female and it's
covered with sperm from the previous male.
It inseminated that female. Oh, so he's
brushing out the other guys. Exactly.
That's rather shocking. Yup.
Batter's still better still is
the duck the duck, the duck.
Most birds don't have
appears male birds. Ducks do.
That's it. No, it goes on
across different ducks species.
The penis size varies from
very small to about 14 inches.
I mean, absolutely astronomical
on relatively small duck.
And the thing about the duck is,
I don't quite know how to put this
ducks engage in forced extra pair
copulations. What he's really
saying is that the males are,
are they're raping the females. Oh wait.
Because the females have a strategy
of there. A couple of years ago,
we were dissecting a female duck and a
postdoc called Patty Brennan called me
into the, and she said, look at this.
I've just found this funny
structure in the female's vagina,
and what it was was a side-branch,
meaning instead of one, you know,
clear highway, right to the egg. This
one had a kind of off ramp off ramp.
I phoned a colleague in France who was a
duck expert and he said he'd never seen
such a thing but give him 10
minutes and he'll go and check.
So he obviously went off and dissected
his own duck. He phoned me back and said,
my God, you're right there.
It was an off ramp in the fringe dock by
which time we'd finished our dissection
and in fact,
when the British took a look at their
dock and the duck that we looked at,
there were two or three
separate side branches.
Patty then went on to do a comparative
study of a lot of different duck species.
And what we found was that in species
where the nail had an enormous fallows,
the female had the most complex
vagina we'd ever come across.
Some had two or three side
branches and a very long spiral,
like a cook screw or the end of the
vagina. And if you think about it,
what seems very likely here is that
the female has got these structures to
deflect the male. If she's being raped,
she might contract part of
her reproductive tract to
send the mail off down a
blind alley. If he avoids that,
she can just tighten up the spiral so
his sperm can't get to the right place.
So what you've got here is a kind of
warfare. The mail says, all right,
I'm coming in there like it
or not. And then the female
is, well, you're getting
nowhere like it or not
go female ducks.
Remarkable case of females evolving
counter adaptations to keep males at arms
length. Well,
penis is length so to speak.
Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye.
Aye. So this is maverick and buckles,
African group.
The British male science is section of
our protein who's coming easily to a
pause so we can meet an American and
a female. My name is Joanna Ellington.
Joanna Ellington, I'm a phd
in reproductive physiology.
We spoke with her at her
farm in Washington state.
So we have a 70 acres here and I was
a veterinarian before I did my phd.
You are an andrologist? Yes.
An andrologist is study
of male reproduction and
dro for man and allergy is
study of, yeah. Yeah. Are
the big, they're right there.
Pigs are over here sleeping.
They're going to be bred today.
We actually have semen flying in from the
basket and we're going to go down here
to the chicken coop. And while
she's walking into the chicken coop,
let me just say,
we finally come to a human sparing
expert to ask Jerry about us. Yeah.
And as, I mean, this competition thing,
does it work like that with
those ginger? No part. Well,
that's the real surprise to me. I mean,
we've all seen the sex education films.
You know when you're in fourth grade,
the woman's own defense
system attacks the sperm.
They are unwelcome cells from another
organism and they are potential enemies.
But
when Joanna gave me her version of
all this, it was not like that at all.
Let me, let me start from
the beginning. First,
this firm have to get through the cervix.
The woman's cervical mucus has a lot
of fibers in it that are crisscrossed,
so you think it'd be this big mesh
barrier they couldn't get through.
The barriers are numerous by
when women are [inaudible].
The hormones in her body make all
those fibers in the cervical mucus
lineup and they basically make a
little highway that the sperm can swim,
Zip, Zip, zip. Not only
is she welcoming the man,
he's making sure later
that they don't get along.
They're directed to the side that has
the egg on it all because there's some
tubes with eggs and
some twos without right.
One Fallopian Tube leads
to the waiting game.
The other to an empty tomb except for
the woman's body says over here, guys,
this site this night and most surprising
of all is that halfway through the
journey there's a a rest period n
it was called the Fallopian Tube.
The Fallopian Tube says, oh great,
we know that you guys are here.
We know that you're pretty fragile guys,
so we're going to change the type
of sugar proteins that we make.
We're going to make sugar proteins that
you're bathed in and you just hang out
here until an egg comes. Oh, so
we're now in the waiting room.
Yes, and we're being sugar.
Yes. This sounds nice.
It is nice. That was like
a little Roman moment.
Everybody's lying down and kind of
getting a towel wash or something.
They're very quiet at that point.
Metabolically, they're quiet.
The female is essentially coming in
the
[inaudible].
They can live in the
Fallopian tube for two, three,
four days, maybe even a
week. Oh Week. No kidding.
Until her egg is ready. That's when
she said, hey, we just odd related.
You need to let the guys go.
[inaudible]
are released and starts
swimming up the track.
They swim dense functions to meet the
egg in search of the aid and the rest of
it. Of course. You know
[inaudible]
never heard about the sugar room before.
I mean that seems like news you have
to in the Fallopian didn't. Yeah,
neither had I, this had been
discussed by scientists,
but there was no evidence
to prove that it was so,
uh, but Joanna as a good scientist,
she was the first to provide the evidence.
She said, after I had my last son,
I told my doctor, I said, my husband
and I are going to have intercourse.
You are going to do your
mind Tubal ligation and cut
out my tube and we're going
to get pictures of the sperm stored in
the Human Fallopian tube. So we did.
So you counted your husband's
guys? Yes. Yes. At the gate. Yeah.
There weren't very many. There were
just a few. How many were there?
He had about 20 in the Fallopian
tube that we looked at.
Oh man, that seems like a fragile
[inaudible] low number. Well it is,
but you have to remember
that you only need one.
Wow. That blows my mind. I
mean it's like 20 little. Yeah,
I'm sure lost at the gate.
The cool thing is that yes,
there is this level of competition still,
but underneath there is
this substrate of male
female cooperation.
It's much more inactive teamwork
than one would have supposed
Hazel sperm just arrived. But I'd let
you guys know. Oh, get pregnant. Yeah,
they're going to get pregnant.
Oh, she, that's her pet
boxer w what is it? It's
a white styrofoam cooler.
Go ahead and scratch
Hazel's back. Say Gee,
we'll end up putting probably about
a half a cat into Hazel. Yeah.
How long did it take Mr pig to
make a half a cup? Pigs, man.
A lot of spam. Rubber ces
now. Seven that, Ya know,
come on. Wait, we got to go gray. Sorry.
We're going to miss some
stuff about the pig Radiolab.
We'll continue in a moment.
Message one radio lab is funded in
part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation.
The corporation for public broadcasting
and the National Science Foundation.
Radio lab is produced by W N Y C and
distributed by national public radio.
And this message.
Hi, I'm Abby Jacobson and you may know
me from my fifth TV show, broad city,
but before that I went to art school.
And why am I telling you that? Well,
it's because I have a
podcast baby about art.
It's called a piece of work. It's a
collab between me, w NYC studios and Moma.
I'll talk art with some of my
friends like Questlove, Tavi,
Gevinson and RuPaul and we'll consult
some experts and learn some incredible
things.
Listen to a piece of work with Abby
Jacobson wherever you get your podcasts.
Hello, I'm Jan [inaudible]. I'm
Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
Our topic today is berm
actually. That's right.
And what is a sperm if not one
teeny tiny little a dad. Oh,
it's much more than that. No,
it's the soul. If everything,
well we'll get it just to leave you in
the garage and turn to Kathleen Labounty
who a few years ago sat down to
try to draw a picture of her dad.
And this is the picture that she
drew. I drew a picture of a sperm,
it isn't very impressive.
It was like a cartoon sperm
with blue eyes and brown hair
and a little bit of a mustache.
And then I had a really big question
mark behind the sperm and that was to
represent the fact that, I
don't know this man's identity.
This might sound like your typical
magic market paints a sperm donor story,
but it's really not. And here to tell
us about it is reporter Harry Daniels.
Should I, should I just kind of
take it from the top? Yeah. Okay.
Kathleen lives in Houston and when she
was eight her mom began telling her
rather repeatedly, Kathleen,
there's something special about you.
And I really wasn't that curious,
but she kept saying it so many times
that eventually I decided, okay,
what is it that makes me different? So
she took me upstairs, sat on my bed,
and she just said that the man who
raised you is not your biological father.
We had to go to the sperm bank and that
a very nice man gave us his berm so that
you could be born.
And then she said that I could still
consider my dad to be my father,
even though he wasn't my biological
father. Right afterwards,
I just ran downstairs and I threw my arms
around my dad's neck and he was on the
computer and I just told him that I left
him and he didn't know that I had just
been told that I wasn't
his biological daughter,
so she just took it in and it was
a source of joy for her initially.
It felt kind of magical.
It felt magical. Yeah,
it was just unique. It
didn't completely sink in.
At first
[inaudible]
things started to change as she got older.
She just became aware of all these things
that were different between me and my
family. Okay. So I've gotten the
picture out if me and my cousins,
so I'm feeling like FedEx,
I kind of don't blend in.
The obvious thing is my height.
I'm five two and all of my cousins
are between five 10 and six five.
Wow. Wow. That's like a foot taller.
Right. So that was one thing.
And then there were lots of other
things, like she had blue eyes,
whereas the rest of her family had
mainly Brown and she had these drawing
abilities. My mom, she can
barely draw stick figures.
She's a vegetarian and
the only one in my family.
And so I was kind of wondering if that
desired to take care of anything living
maybe came from him.
It just became more curious about
how this man contributed to who I am.
What did you know about him? The only
information that I got is that he,
he attended Baylor called to medicine.
Baylor is where Texas in
1981 when I was conceived,
but I don't know if he was a first year,
second, third or fourth year student.
And that's it. Correct. That
was us as brain much. Yeah.
So when she was a teenager,
she contacted the clinic trying to request
medical records and I was told that
they were destroyed years ago. I
felt like I had lost part of me.
So can she solve this in any way?
What is she going to do? Well,
one night when she was in college,
and this was a few years later,
her mom just happened to
be watching TV every year,
30,000 children are born in this country.
The mothers who had been artificially
inseminated with sperm from an anonymous
donor and she saw a special about
the generous sibling registry,
our base called the donor sibling
registry.com oh, it's a website.
So website we try to help donors and donor
offspring and half siblings find each
other. CBS News 60 minutes. So
after my mother saw this show,
I decided to register.
So she logged on pest clinic and
she put into the search engine,
Baylor College of Medicine [inaudible].
And there was actually a girl around
my age, young woman named Jessica,
which means they could be sisters.
Say she and I got in touch and
started to talk right away.
They noticed. They had a
lot of things in common.
We both had polycystic ovarian syndrome,
which is a genetic syndrome that you
would inherit and we are on the exact same
medication and the same dosage and that
seemed like more than a coincidence.
Kind of sparked our curiosity and so
they decided that they would meet up.
She came and spent a weekend with me.
By the time she left we had come up
with a list of a hundred similarities,
a hundred on our list. We have that.
We can't roll our tongues bed
born in 1982 but have curly hair.
We both had high cholesterol. Don't
have any sense of direction. This is,
this is what you do when you
want something to be true,
but had butterfly tattoos absolutely had
the same taste in music when you eat.
I think want to believe
we are very thoughtful.
All these things that would otherwise I
think maybe escape detects, have that.
Our handwriting was pretty similar. All
of a sudden become really important.
That just goes on and on.
So they decided to have a DNA test
and and the results come back.
They called her and then she called me.
I mean you can hear people's
disappointment and sadness.
So I knew before she said anything
[inaudible]
I think of it as a 0.001% probability
that we were sisters just like that this
possibility was gone. They
began to feel loss and grief.
Like I look in the mirror and I
see a stranger looking back at me.
Okay, so fast forward
now a couple of years,
she goes to a library, a
library, and the medical center,
she walks over to the stacks,
pulls out old Baylor yearbooks,
the old Baylor what your books.
She figured as long as he showed up to
get his picture taken on picture day,
he'd be in one of those books. Exactly.
So I take them off the shelf
and I photocopied every page,
your pegs say 19
791980818283 and 84 year old
letters and she took them home.
I was expecting just to flip through it
and not see any similarities with any of
the men and then get to
one picture and think, hey,
this is the man. But that's
definitely not what happened. Instead,
I realized that I looked like dozens
if not hundreds of the men. Let's see,
and I would think that I had
one man's news and this guy,
another man's eyes in prison, another
one, the other man's chin. Even this guy,
I mean, I think it's possible because
the rounded eyebrows and bigger eyes.
I just got overwhelmed so she
decided to enlist some help. Right?
So I had my mom and three of my closest
friends take sticky tabs and flip
through the photos of all of the men.
He has blue eyes. They might say, Molly,
you kind of look like this man,
or you kind of look like this
other man or smiles or similar,
and then they would mark the man who
they thought resembled me, the meadows.
She then decided she would draft
a letter, a letter. Dear doctor,
it is after match thought that I am
you. I was thinking, well, all right.
The men who were consistently picked
out, it was conceived May 4th,
1981 by an anonymous sperm donation
through a Baylor called to medicine
students. I tried to think,
okay, if I were a donor,
what would my concern speed.
I want to assure you that I am
emotionally stable and financially secure,
provide additional reassurance to donors.
I have been using a non legally binding
DNA test that cannot be used in court
and then I just explained in many ways,
okay I that even if I tried to give
an overview of who I am, I have large,
I'm these navy blue eyes.
I barely reached five to both my
mother and I have a positive blood.
I am attaching my photographs to see if
you recognize my face and then I just
said thank you for your
time. Sincerely Kathleen.
And so she actually sends
it out the letter. Yeah,
around 25 letters to the men
that looked most like her.
Another round of 50 my biggest fear
was that my letters would not be
acknowledged.
I had been told for so long that my
donor wouldn't want to know about me.
He wouldn't care that I exist and
I thought if I send out 25 letters,
maybe one would take the time to respond
to me. Did she get anything back?
She did what they say. Well, I mean
some of them more what you might expect.
Wow. Your letter was
unexpected. Dear Kathleen,
take me off your mailing list and
do you not ever contact me again?
I remember just before my shift started,
it was a 10:30 AM a rummage through
the mailbox and saw a letter that was
addressed to myself, Dr. Daniel
Zack. I live just outside Seattle.
And I remember, um,
practice emergency medicine
opening the letter and uh,
the first sentence or two I thought, oh,
oh see, here's one that's handwritten.
I was assured that it would be anonymous
and that there would be no way for
anyone to track me down
even if they wanted to.
That your motivations may be innocent.
Please consider the ramifications
for others by the knowledge you seek.
I felt that I would never be contacted.
Good. But then there were
others, like this guy,
I think I called her, um,
right away I'm Merryman Baker.
I'm an orthopedic surgeon who's, uh,
lives in the Houston area. And I said,
well, I was a donor I think
25 years ago. And, uh,
I never thought this day would
come. What does that mean to he?
You know, I wrote this one
line down that he said, um,
he said that's how really
good things happen. You know,
usually the way really good things happen,
they come out of the blue. Uh, I'm,
I'm 51 now and I don't
have any kids, you know,
not having kids would be the last
thing I would have guessed, you know,
35 or 40 years ago from
my own perspective.
But I've always been very work oriented.
All of a sudden you kind
of look up and, you know,
a few years have passed by and
you don't have any kids yet.
So the prospect of, uh,
of having, you know,
a daughter out there somewhere
that I didn't know bad was,
was quite frankly a kind of a, a rush.
He called me and, um,
we just talked about our interests and
our personality and we started finding
similarities.
Her mother had a, requested a
blue eyed donor, which I am.
She has a positive blood, which
would be compatible with mine.
And it gets even more, uh,
Erie [inaudible] Oh gee,
my major in college and our cumulative
grade point average was identical.
She certainly could be my daughter on
many fronts because I spoke with my mother
at length.
She was extraordinarily excited that the
prospect of having a grandchild and she
prepared a place for her at a Christmas
dinner with her name on it. Wow.
Today they get the DNA test. Not
Exactly. They just kept waiting.
Probably subconsciously. I almost
didn't really want to know.
Right. You know, let's just not even
open up the results of the test.
Let's just assume that we're, it's
a match. We get along so well,
why does it matter? But at the same time,
we both knew that we
needed to know the truth.
In the end. They finally
went through with it. I mean,
it was kind of a running lottery
about, you know, what do you think?
And I was pretty, uh,
impressed at the fact that it was
probably going to be positive.
[inaudible]
the results come back from the lab and it
looks like yellow. It's basic information,
[inaudible] information about
this and that in terms of the DNA,
I have no idea what blue, green, gray,
pink. Then at the bottom it's, it's,
you know, kind of yes or no.
The probability equals 0%.
It was like 0% chance
that it was positive.
He wrote me and he said, I'm heartbroken.
I'm so sorry this was negative.
And um,
I think it took him about three or four
weeks before he felt up to speaking to
me again.
Yes.
Yeah. I mean, I've always thought
I'd be a good dad and you know, I,
I guess it was Kinda like,
it would've been kind of Nice to have
a child out there who's well adjusted,
a intelligent person. Yeah.
It's kind of all the things
you'd want your kid to be.
Yeah.
And that's what all I've made.
It's made me stop my search.
[inaudible]
so did she stop then for the,
she does exactly the opposite.
I wrote every single male who went to
Baylor from 79 to 84 which is how many
males? 600 out of those 600,
250 responded. Wow. Half
of them greater back. Yeah.
That's so weird. Exactly.
That was exactly my reaction.
Weird are still, not only did they
respond, but they were very supportive.
Dear Miss Labounty,
you are clearly someone who thinks and
feels deeply that makes you special.
One guy sent me a card, you sound and
look like a remarkable young woman.
This one says, I would
claim you in a second.
I'm trying to read his handwriting.
Doctor's handwriting. Dear Kathleen,
I've waited 26 years to receive a
letter like this and this is man who's
actually a friend of mine now.
I've met him and I've met his wife.
This one's really sweet too.
Well, we'll wait about, what about that
guy at the beginning that I went, oh,
Dr Dan Zack. Yeah, him
even he came around.
As time has progressed since
I initially read the letter.
Now I'm almost sorry that
she's not my biologic daughter.
That would have been kind of
fun and have all those has,
has anyone else agree
to do a paternity test?
All told she's had 16 DNA tests
of the alternate negative. Every,
every test came back as negative,
but I still feel like I probably
have the answer in front of me.
I just don't know which
pages is [inaudible]
it just, it just real quick. So I
realize it's 12 now. Um, the, the song,
I don't know a few. I mean I was
just thinking about that too.
[inaudible] some of it.
Okay. I just need it.
Hello?
Um,
[inaudible]
well, whenever I've heard
somewhere out there,
ever since I was a kid it would remind
me of my biological father and that he's
out there when I was a kid.
Sometimes I'd look up at the
sky and I would think that I,
I literally know nothing about my father
except that we were both looking at the
exact same size.
[inaudible]
yeah, that's as far as they got.
That's as far as you got. [inaudible]
I never learned the engine.
I'm still working on,
yeah,
that story from Ra Daniel Shapiro
and Lulu Miller, our producer,
time for a break. Radiolab
will continue in a moment.
This is Adrian Stein from
New Brunswick, New Jersey.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing
public understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hello, I'm Janet. Boom, Rhonda. And
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab.
Our topic today is sperm
Yellow Wigley cell that uh,
along with male pattern baldness teams
should describe everything you need to
know about being a man. Speaking of which,
let's ask now one of the bigger questions
that you can ask in a show about
sperm, which is why are their
sperm, why are there men? What,
why are there men? This is a real
question of biological question,
which is completely baffling.
That is Steve Jones. Hello,
I'm professor of genetics at
University College London.
He wrote a book called the descent of Man,
where he speculates about how we men
got our start and why we've managed to
stick around so long. That's the
real question. Here's this theory.
Let's imagine ourselves in
the primordial soup. Okay.
3000 million years ago was actually
minestrone because it was lumpy, right?
And the lumps, the sounds,
and to reproduce these sounds,
what they have to do is gather up
their energy and all on their own.
It's split in half. [inaudible]
make copies of themselves,
which are more or less identical.
Most of the time the normal flow of events
is these cells are coming and coming
and coming. Every so often
there would be a copying error.
Hello, a mutation. These are
happening all the time. Hi, hello.
Most were harmless,
but not so much in the one
of these mutations cause
the cell that we saved it to
behave in a different way. This new cell,
how you do it through
the randomness of nature,
it had acquired a talent
instead of dividing on its own.
It figured out that it could save some
energy if it could swim up to another
cell. Hello Burrow. It's way in
and forced that second cell to divide.
By so doing, not only was
it avoiding a lot of work,
it was copying its own
genes at that that moment
males were born.
How do you, how are you [inaudible]
that's what you're saying is that guys
are essentially moochers like they left,
we got our start. According to this
theory, males began with selfishness.
These little cells began to mooch off
of other cells. Then they figured out,
you know, over time they could
much better if they got smaller,
small and faster and as mobile as they
possibly can because then they can fuse
with more and more of the other kinds
of sales and persuade them to divide.
So now, yeah,
if you want a definition that encompasses
all males everywhere from oak trees to
elephants to humans to fish,
there's only one real universal
definition of what it means to be male.
It's the sex that makes small sex sells
and often lots of them. That's it.
We make the small sex sells.
Not really is the mark of the male
having a tiny sexer meaning you,
me, Steve. Yeah. At the core of it,
our maleness is defined by these
little tiny swimming packets of genes,
what we now call sperm,
but we know we don't,
I don't understand if all
males are, are parasites. Yeah.
Yeah. But why would the female
cells allow us to do that?
Why don't they just say go away?
And that's a big question because there
are some species that have dispensed
with males altogether. Really? Yes.
The one that comes to mind is a
California Lizard, which is quite common.
It's called the whip tail lizard.
And they live in the Mojave desert and
they're all female as far as we can see
that I've not been no males
around for a long, long time.
It's kind of strange because they actually
caught each other and one female gets
on top of the other and
tries to mate with it.
So there's some kind of remnant of
male behavior, but that all female.
But how has it that, did they make little
lizards? They just produce adjuncts,
which develop into lizards. Oh,
they just don't bother with males.
So the baby is identical to the mommy.
So we're not gonna have a cloning here.
Yeah. You know, plenty of birds can do
that. I mean, chickens often lay eggs,
which develop and hadn't
been fertilized frogs.
He says there's some frogs that can
do it too. But here's the thing,
even though making babies without
men is green, as some scientists,
the most efficient way to do it, to
reproduce, it's still pretty rare.
There are very few land
vertebrates, which are all female.
Which brings us back
to your question, why?
Why do females not make
huge efforts to escape from?
Why are we here? Why have males
hung around this long? I mean,
we shouldn't be doing this program.
Somebody named Alice and someone named
Laura should be here. Hi, I'm Alice,
a boomer. I'm Laura Cro and this
is really not so fast. Ladies,
we're still here now. That's
for why we're still here.
There are tons of theories. Steve's
best guess is that, you know what?
We're not just parasites. We do offer the
ladies one thing in return. Like what?
Well Lulu, going back to the soupy
days at the beginning, just imagine,
says Steve, what if that's
super PC is changing?
Then the water's getting warmer
and the water is getting salty.
So let's say on one side
of the pond there's a cell
that mutates and suddenly it
can handle warm water. On the other side,
there's a cell that mutates and
suddenly it can handle salt.
If this is an all female world,
the warms would copy themselves.
Saltings would copy themselves in.
Every new member of both of these tribes
would die for the waters both warm and
salty cause they couldn't combine
their talents. But if one of the ses,
salty sells as a male, how you doing?
Well that male can swim up to a warm,
he sailed do his mail and Bader thing and
then the next generation anti warm and
anti salt can get together.
So that's what males do.
They bring female lines together
and allow them to mix their genes.
And that may be,
that may be so important says to you that
the only time you can do without meals
is if your world is static. Wait,
what about the lizards? Yeah,
well that's the interesting question
and I think the answer is maybe,
and then we would kind of guesswork
here. They live out in the desert.
The desert doesn't change very
much. The enemy is always the same,
which is hate children's. Your food.
That enemy isn't something
like disease or parasites,
which are constantly evolving themselves
so they can afford to get one set of
genes which are very effective,
clone themselves by not having sex,
whereas other creatures can't.
Does that mean you think that
if our world were like that,
that if we'd somehow perfected
it, that we wouldn't need men?
That's arguably true. Um,
and somebody does it on the doorbell now.
That's now still, hang on.
We got another bloody nuclear explosion
on the right sided Jesus Christ is
normally quite as the
grave in here. Okay, right?
[inaudible]
if we lived in a, in an unchanging
world, maybe we wouldn't need men,
but we don't live in a world that
doesn't change. Look at the AIDS virus.
Look at bird flu. They're out there.
They're waiting to get you and they're
going to get lots of us sooner or later
with a new epidemic, which
itself has changed genetically.
And you're going to need the males to
mix up the genes to make sure that the
whole species doesn't just
disappear. So that you know,
I think we males do for a brief moment
of quiet self-congratulation Robert,
I've never told you this, but you're a
really good guy and you are spectacular.
Thanks. Yeah.
The prospect of a world with a man seemed
remote until the invention of the deep
freeze
because he can freeze, burn and use it.
I do like blue eyes,
get that one mensa and it can be used
after that death and maybe I'm not ready
yet.
So the don't congratulate yourself that
you're always going to have a world with
men in it. You may just
have a world with freezers.
Steve Jones wrote the book.
Why the descent of men moving right along
the idea of like a world without men
or a world where men have been replaced
by freezers. Men replaced by freezers.
It's sperm frozen in the speeding
freezer. Yeah. Yeah. Whatever.
That's frozen men. Yes.
Frozen little baby man.
I wanna I want to tell you a story that's
gonna wipe that smile right off your
face. Krulwich it's a, it comes
from one of our favorite reporters.
NPRs Nell Greenfield boys.
Hello Radiolab. Hello.
So should I just introduce this person?
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Um, my name is
Alisha Naval Taylor. You shouldn't evil
Taylor and I live in Oshkosh, Wisconsin.
Basically. Um, I love animals. Back
in 1995, Alicia and her husband John,
were living in New York City. Uh,
Melson fested cheesy
little dump in park slope.
They were this young
couple in their thirties.
She was working at like a daycare center.
I did basically creative movement with
little kids under five and he was a super
in this big apartment building on the
upper east side and she and her husband
both got some horrible flu and I can
remember laying in bed, both of n we were,
we flipped a quarter to see who would
go make the can of chicken noodle soup.
And I said, what would we
do if we had kids right now?
And I can remember laying there in
their bed and John Goes, we'd set,
we'd set that child up right there on
the floor and throw some toys down there
and we'd both lean over the
edge. I had never been so sick.
Did she have any idea what made them
sick? Nope. Just one of those things. And,
and you know she got, what
about him? He didn't get better.
He was throwing up cold cough.
Did you guys think it was
just like the flu? Yeah, we,
I mean we just thought he was getting
sicker and sicker and at some point he was
like having trouble kind of breathing.
And so Alicia was just like,
we're going to the emergency room. They
wheeled him into the emergency room.
First nurse we see, she says, oh my
God, John, why did you wait so long?
All of a sudden he's like in
the ICU. But it's funny though,
while John was in the hospital,
I snapped three photographs of
him was going to say to him,
see what you put me through, see what
they would see. Would you look like?
Cause I don't think he
would have ever believed,
okay,
how many tubes and how many
things were coming out of him.
Couple of days later he had a cardiac
arrest and after that he's brain dead.
[inaudible]
and I went home that night. You know,
it's, I'm right across the street.
I went home and I, I saw our
whole lives go right out the door.
I was, as I looked out
over that East River,
um,
I saw the kids. We weren't going to have
did that fear of, Oh my God,
I'm gonna lose everything.
And then she remembered something,
something that had happened about
six months before John and I had seen
something on the news hours
after Anthony Baez died in a
confrontation with police. He's widow,
told her sister-in-law,
I want his [inaudible]
baby. This one day
before she went to work,
she had seen this report
about a man who had died,
a young man who had died and when
he was lying there in the morgue,
family members of his wife
actually said to the doctors,
is there any way that
you can save his sperm?
The family called in in New York hospital,
urologist Peter Schlegel
and Peter Schlegel and I'm
urologist and chief at New
York Presbyterian hospital who had
removed sperm from many men before,
but never a dead one. Had you
been to the morgue before? Nope.
It's probably not quite as clean as on TV.
And certainly working with
a dead body is different.
Schlegel says Mrs Baez would have an
excellent chance of conceiving with the
sperm he retrieved if that's what she
decides to do. Warren Levinson, New York.
Yeah. And
I said to John, I go, wow, is that wild
or what? What do you think of that?
She said that John was
like in the bathroom. No,
I mean he was brushing
his teeth, you know,
in his usual rush to get off to work.
And she said to him like, if you died,
would you be okay with me doing nice as
well? If it's really tragic, he goes,
go for it. Then later on she went to work.
Remember she works at like this daycare
kind of center [inaudible] and she
mentioned it to somebody at work and one
of the women who works there pointed to
a kid and said, you see that kid?
His father is the doctor who
removed the sperm. Wow. No kidding.
And so she's remembering all of
this. Six months later, I would,
oh, that little boy, his dad, you know,
her husband is brain dead at this point.
And what she decides to do is go to
work and find the name of that kid whose
father had taken the sperm. So you
pick up the phone and [inaudible]
got an appointment with him right away.
That Wednesday I went and saw Peter
Schlagel and they had Thursday John,
he died around six o'clock.
Sorry,
I'm really sorry.
Oh wait, we're best friends.
A team came in to his
room. She waited outside.
What do you actually need
to do a procedure like this?
Basically a vasectomy cat. They take
a needle, put it into the man's body.
One of the richest sources
of sperm would be the vast,
the tube that normally carries sperm
from the area around the testicles to the
ejaculate Teri regions.
They literally put the needle into
that too and suck the sperm out.
So you're left with a little one inch
tall conical tube that has tens of
millions or maybe even hundreds
of millions of sperm within it.
[inaudible],
you know, I can't help but
ask myself the question.
Well maybe I'll just ask you,
would you do this? Absolutely.
Really no question in my mind.
So I've been married eight years,
I don't have children.
I want to have children with my husband
and if he died I would absolutely do it.
And no ethicist at a hospital is going
to be able to tell me no because I got my
husband to put it in his will. Why?
So that there would be no question if he
died that I would have permission to do
this. But why are you so
certain? Isn't that partying?
It's a little hesitant about
it. W what it really means.
What would it really mean? I
don't know that you're somehow,
I mean at the very least a kid without
a dad and also like the kid would have
your husband's eyes and his nose and his
ears and so he would be kinda like an
echo of him or reminder. There is
nothing that I would want more honestly.
I mean, you know, if my husband died,
there was nothing I would want more than,
than a child of his. But
you know, Peter Schlegel,
what Peter Schlegel told me
is that in most cases
women do not use the sport.
Women will not go forward and use
those farms. Really? They collect it,
time passes, maybe they meet someone else
and decide to move on with their life.
That's interesting. And what about
Leisha? Did she, uh, did she move on?
Well, no. If I,
if I was standing at 70 and
looking back at my life,
then I'd have to kick
myself. If I didn't do this,
it would have been out of fear that I
didn't because everybody kind of looks at
it like, God, that's so weird. That's
what are you going to tell this kid? Oh,
you came from somebody's dad.
How would you explain this to
your child and simply will the,
with the truth. I loved
your father. He died.
I saved us from post-mortem so that
I could bring you into the world.
You are indeed a part of him
and you are indeed a part of me.
After John Died, she moved back to
Wisconsin and she waited for awhile.
Her life was moving on. She had
relationships with other people,
but she didn't let go
of the idea. Finally,
six years after her husband died, she
decided that she was going to do it.
I think it really came down to me making
a decision about doing it on my own.
You know,
she called and she made an appointment
at a fertility clinic back in New York.
I had gone out in September
like the day before the um,
planes flew into the
World Trade Center and
the city felt some Felicia,
it seemed like signs were
everywhere. Signs of fate. I guess.
There was just such a big part in
the coincidences. Like what, what was
pretty amazing in that the in vitro
center was in the building or John and I
made love, I mean it was in that building,
you know,
the doctor's office where she was getting
the fertility treatments were in her
old building. It was such a coincidence
that she'd even seen that news report.
The fact that it was the doctors,
little boy I was teaching
her cat died, you know,
while she was in New York and she sort
of had this idea that with this death,
this life comes, things were were dying,
but there was going to be new life.
I had all these
zag sudden the chances of
it working were really big.
I was for sure going to get pregnant,
you know, all of these
things just came together.
So that felt natural and right.
A fertility clinic technician thought
this frozen six year old sperm injected it
into the eggs and then they waited.
I mean had you like gotten
nursery stuff ready and stuff?
Like were you at that point
level of certainty gone out
shocked and yeah, I,
I had it all picked out,
but none of the eggs fertilized, none.
None.
It was like another death. I mean it
was just, it was like another death.
She had told me
that she had John Cremated and that
she had sort of half of his ashes,
I'm still in her house and that she didn't
know really what she was going to do
with them, that she knew at some point
she had to scatter them or something,
but she hadn't really worked out a plan.
And you know, I pointed out that, well,
she's got the sperm store too. Like,
do you think that that's something that
you want to somehow do something with or
will it be there forever
until there's a power outage
now? Just, I'm so cynical. Um,
it doesn't amount to anything.
It's, it's the, the thing
that's there that isn't,
it's like the chair. It's,
it's not who he is or was.
[inaudible]
no greenfield boys. Thanks to her.
Thank you to a NPR and NPR science desk.
Anything you heard today you
can hear again on our website,
radiolab.org our email addresses
radio lab@wnyc.org. I'm Janet,
I'm Rod and I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks.